bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy hablaremos del novio que el
agente nervioso con que fue envenenado
el opositor ruso alexéi navalni según
alemania el contexto es el siguiente
naval
de 44 años férreo opositor de vladimir
putin líder de masivas manifestaciones
que le han valido varias semanas en la
cárcel sufrió un colapso el 20 de agosto
de 2020 que lo puso en estado de coma su
traslado a berlín para ser atendido ha
sido crucial en la teoría del
envenenamiento él no ha dicho que fue
hallado en naval ni es un agente
nervioso que data de la guerra fría los
químicos de la ex unión soviética
desarrollaron una sustancia letal en el
marco de un programa de armas químicas
que era secreto de estado
el objetivo era equipararse a la nueva
generación de armas binarias
estadounidenses escuchemos a una experta
británica al respecto
los componentes del novillo que en
realidad se fabricaron en los años 70 y
80 en la ex unión soviética
la razón por la que se fabricaron fue
porque querían eludir el tratado de
armas químicas por lo que para ello
fabricaron dos componentes separados que
no eran tóxicos pero que cuando se
mezclaban formaban un agente nervioso y
la gravedad de la acción era mayor que
la de los agentes nerviosos anteriores
conocidos
en la guerra química entre eeuu y la
unión soviética el hallazgo de las armas
binarias constituía un éxito a sabiendas
que los venenos militares son tan
altamente tóxicos que ponen en riesgo la
vida de la persona que los opera los
agentes compuestos ofrecían una relativa
calma de acuerdo con el centro
estadounidense de biotecnología y basado
en las memorias del doctor bill mesta
janoff un antiguo jefe soviético que de
belo en 1994 el desarme de las armas
químicas en rusia se pudo saber que dos
sustancias que por sí solas pueden ser
inofensivas al combinarlas podrían
activarse y sintetizarse en un poderoso
agente nervioso se les llama así
es un veneno que afecta este sistema del
cuerpo humano inhibiendo la enzima
acetilcolinesterasa fundamental para la
contracción de músculos ese viaje
consiste en venir y se hace difícil
respirar y con una dosis más alta deja
de respirar y comienzas a tener
convulsiones y luego a vomitar
he visto el efecto en animales conejos y
perros es verdaderamente abominable
y tras dos décadas de trabajo químico
los líderes soviéticos desestimaron la
fabricación masiva del novillo que
vladimir google uno de los jefes
científicos del programa aseguró que el
no que se fabricó únicamente a
escala de laboratorio y se llegó a
almacenar aproximadamente 100 kilos pero
una poca concentración de la gente puede
ser mortal como le sucedió a andrei
seleznyov un científico soviético que
fue expuesto al novillo por un error de
manipulación en un laboratorio de 1987
en una entrevista que sólo vio la luz en
1992 dijo aparecieron círculos ante mis
ojos rojos y naranjas un zumbido en mis
oídos y contuve mi respiración una
sensación de miedo como si algo
estuviera a punto de suceder me senté en
una silla y le dije a los compañeros me
dio andréis el ssn yákov tardó un año en
morir después de que el no
secuestrar a su sistema nervioso central
sufrió de cirrosis hepatitis tóxica y
epilepsia
pero su testimonio público alimentó la
causa de parar definitivamente con el
desarrollo del programa de armas
químicas
pese a que george bush padre y mijail
gorbachov habían firmado el acuerdo de
armas químicas en 1990 en el cual eeuu y
la unión soviética se comprometían a
detener la producción de este tipo de
armas el diario británico the guardian
constata que varios científicos
denunciaron que en esa década de final
del siglo 20 la producción continuaba en
secreto finalmente en 1997 entró en
vigor la convención de armas químicas
que prohibió rotundamente el desarrollo
la producción el almacenamiento y el uso
de estas armas pero desde el caso de
zelaya coffee su incidente en el
laboratorio no se había conocido otro
caso de envenenamiento de novi shop sino
hasta marzo de 2018
para entonces el ex espía ruso serguéi
skripal y su hija giulia fueron
envenenados en salisbury reino unido con
este agente nervioso las investigaciones
arrojaron que detrás del intento de
homicidio de skripal quien había actuado
como agente doble en el m16 británico
estaba en rusia la razón sería la alta
traición a pesar que el gas puso a hacer
que skripal y su hija en un estado de
salud crítico ambos sobrevivieron y
fueron dados de alta dos meses después
desde entonces el kremlin siempre ha
negado cualquier participación tanto en
el caso de skripal como el de naval ni
el envenenamiento del ex agente doble
serguéi skripal podría ser de interés
para el gobierno británico que se
encontró en una situación incómoda al no
haber cumplido las promesas a su
electorado sobre las condiciones para el
éxito
y aún cuando el viceministro asuntos
exteriores de rusia dijo que ni la unión
soviética ni rusia han tenido programas
para el desarrollo de una sustancia como
el novillo el científico ruso que debe
la existencia de este agente nervioso lo
desmiente
antes de mi publicación estaba 100%
seguro que sólo rusia 2 había
letras
rusia no comparte con nadie y así
terminamos soy andrés suárez jaramillo
gracias por compartir estas historias
que las encuentran en france 24 punto
com
[Música]